OK.
We've got today kind of like a big catch of
day, going to do a bunch of different stories,
get everybody caught up.
Hopefully some folks tuned out from everything
going on over the weekend.
I know I tried to.
Let's get caught back up and then tomorrow
we're going to have some deeper dives into
some more, some more, some more deeper dives
into some particular elements, as I like to
call them, of what's going on with the virus.
Our response?
The Democratic primary.
So let's get right into it.
Donald Trump has previously floated the idea
of being opened by Easter as a country, clearly
because medical experts have gotten to him.
He has canceled that.
Donald Trump announced yesterday during a
press briefing, which we covered live.
It was outside the White House that we will
be closed until April 30, abiding by those
guidelines.
The social distancing guidelines.
And of course, this is sort of the case because
there are lots of states that are doing very
little so far.
But for the states and the people who have
been distancing, closing nonessential businesses,
et cetera, it's going to be another 32 days
from today until we might be able to start
opening things up.
This is both depressing and frustrating, but
not surprising and clearly necessary.
That's the reality.
It's depressing and necessary in order to
continue fighting the virus.
Here is Donald Trump yesterday announcing
this.
The modeling estimates that the peak in death
rate is likely to hit in two weeks.
So I'll say it again, the peak.
The highest point of death rates.
Remember, this is likely to head into weeks.
Nothing would be worse than declaring victory
before.
The victory is one that would be the greatest
loss of all.
Therefore, the next two weeks and during this
period is very important that every one strongly
follow the guidelines have to follow the guidelines
that are grade vise.
President holds up a lot.
He's holding that up a lot.
He believes in it so strongly.
The better you do, the faster this whole nightmare
will end.
Therefore, we will be extending our guidelines
to April 30th to slow the spread.
And Donald Trump is 100 percent correct.
He's a liar.
He's a bad president.
He's incompetent.
He cares more about his own ratings, as we
will talk about, than the death toll.
But this is the right decision.
And I'll talk to you a little bit about the
peak and the data.
But when he said it, I simultaneously sort
of experience dread and relief.
The numbers are exploding.
The health care system is rapidly getting
closer and closer to being overwhelmed, which
increases the death rate, as we've tragically
seen in other countries, including Italy.
And I'm struggling with it.
I mean, my nature is to be out all the time,
to be in cafes, to be with friends, to be
at the gym, to be with family.
I'm doing none of it.
I've canceled multiple trips.
A major show.
Appearances may be getting canceled, but I've
got electricity.
I'm not sick with the virus for the time being.
And hopefully most of us won't be.
We will be better off in the long run.
And this is the right decision.
Now, as far as the numbers and the peak, there
is very good data.
There's a model that every day is fine tuned
with the latest data from Dr. Christopher
Murray, professor of health metrics sciences,
medical doctor, professor.
Really good study with confidence intervals
about this.
His estimate is that nationally, April 15th
will be the peak date.
That means a 15 more days, 15 more full days
from today.
Now, this is really, really important to understand
because some people here, April 15th, they
think great, that's when it's all wide open.
Others think, no, that can't possibly be.
It seems too soon.
The peak simply means we get to the top.
Not that we necessarily come down from it.
And the doctor expects that the peak will
last a few days, right around 20, 200 deaths
per day.
That's going to be a cluster of about six
days.
April 14th tonight.
During those six days, he estimates somewhere
between twelve and 13000 people will die in
total and then it will start to decline.
Twenty one hundred people will die then, you
know, two thousand and fifty.
So if we are 15 days to the peak and the peak
will last five or six days, that means in
15 plus five plus another 15 days, meaning
35 more days, we'd be back to a day like today.
If you consider the upswing and then the downswing,
we're roughly six to eight hundred people
will die.
We're not sure yet of the exact numbers today.
And in fact, the decline from the peak may
be more spread out at maybe a more gradual
decline than the asset.
The peak, so this is with a confidence interval.
So when you look at the graphic, you see the
dotted line, which says, for example, you
know, 20 271 deaths on April 15th.
But it could be as few as eleven eighty that
day.
It could be as many as thirty five hundred.
That's the range with 22 71 being the number
in between.
So that's what it's looking like now.
And under this estimate, the total deaths
would be about 82000 in the U.S. for this
cycle of the virus.
This is important to understand.
This model doesn't look at the fact that these
pandemics will often have two or three peaks
and the next one may come in the fall.
This is eighty two thousand deaths through
the end of the summer.
Again, that's with a confidence interval.
Could be as low as thirty nine thousand, could
be as high as one hundred forty two thousand
based on the data we have right now.
The better we do with social distancing, the
lower the number is.
And some day things will start to get back
to normal.
But it's going to be months.
And you know, somebody said to me over the
weekend, these things have a beginning, a
middle and an end.
We are past the beginning.
We are definitely in the middle of this right
now.
Hopefully from mid April on, we'll start to
move from the middle to the end, at least
of phase one.
And it's going to be a long fight.
All we can do is take it day by day.
And that's what I'm trying
to do.